as the white house grapples with how to
resolve the migrant surge
americans living along the border are
sounding the alarm on this
crisis our next guest is a rancher from
new mexico
and says that the number of migrants
traveling through her property has
increased drastically
our guest name is amanda adame and she
joins us now good morning to you amanda
good morning good morning doing well i
know you're worried i know you have a
family and you and you think about that
and you don't want anything to go wrong
what are you seeing on a regular basis
now
um the presence of walkers
and a lot a lot of border patrol
trying to catch them so they just walk
through your property how close do they
get to your house
um fairly close a lot of them come into
the house
are you seeing they come into the house
well not in to my house per se but like
down into the yard asking for food and
water
wow do you help them what do you do
yeah we have you know we don't want to
get hurt so
we feed and water them and try to get
them to go on or we come in the house
and
call the border patrol what's
interesting is if you look at the
numbers
they've released all the numbers of
every single sector down there in your
area el paso
you've seen a more than double increase
in the unaccompanied alien children
from this past february to the february
before look at those numbers
uh more than 5 000 came in this past
february when it comes to family units
it's actually down in your area
8 500 last february this past february
almost 6
000 most of them are entering according
to these numbers the rio grande area
and then single adults increased from
more than 12 000 last february to 41
000. why do you think that is do you
have any idea
um i think in part it's the asylum
cooperative agreement that they
terminated
the white administration just basically
gave them a green light to come up
and they're not wanting to get caught
they're trying to run
as fast as they can i know you you've
told our producers that
they aren't afraid
no they're not afraid so when they see a
border agency
and what did they when they would see a
border agent when trump was
president what would they do compared to
what they do now
um when they saw a border agent before
they stopped and they waited
and now they keep trying to go
and do the border agents let them go
no no they catch them when they see them
that's the big problem is when they get
up to my house
essentially they're almost they're
already on american soil and so they're
they're allowed to stay under this
administration
uh last question what's your what's your
biggest concern here
um now that the border policy has
changed what's going to happen now
is what is he going to do with um
stopping asylum seekers i just feel sad
for the people who
are trying to come in legally and they
can't because of all these asylum
seekers
thank you so much for being on with us
stay safe amanda we wish you all the
best thank you